so it's come to my attention that ned
from the try guys has a lot of problems
with his knee being an osteopathic
physician one who has some extra
training in sports medicine i'm excited
to watch this video let's get into it
in fall of 2012 i broke my knee so bad
that it was cut down to the bone and my
friend said this is the day that we saw
ned's kneecap what was cut down i want
to know was his skin like open when
people say break knee i don't know if
it's a fracture of their femur their
tibia their patella which is just the
kneecap it was playing paintball in the
woods in rural new hampshire it's
something called a septic knee i cut my
knee down to the bone and then it got
infected oh okay so what happens in a
septic joint you get this bacterial
infection within the joint space the
knee starts swelling gets real hot it
gets real red what we do in order to
diagnose it actually outside of seeing
that it looks infectious is actually put
in a needle draw fluid out and send it
for testing to see the cell counts to
see if there's white blood cells present
which could be a sign of infection we
also sent a culture of that fluid where
we actually try and grow and cultivate
the bacteria to see what type of
bacteria is present and which
antibiotics it could be resistant to i
had multiple surgeries to clean it out
and my knee was completely destroyed i
was off work for months playing video
games all day it got to the point where
i i
just
taking painkillers was like the best
part of my day
and it was a really um
really scary time yeah it's really scary
because treatment options for
painkillers are quite limited you think
about over-the-counter options you have
your non-steroidal anti-inflammatories
like ibuprofen motrin then you have your
acetaminophen which is like your
tylenols of the world then after that
fairly limited the next line is really
opioid therapy if you have nerve pain
there's some other options like
gabapentin bronton and then we have like
superficial treatment options where you
have non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
enzyme gel like ulterior gel diclofenac
you also have lidocaine patches which
can help numb the area temporarily to
give you healing but long term
we don't have great ways of pain control
except allowing your body a chance to
heal itself oxycodone is an opioid drug
and that's one of the main
factors that's contributing to the
current opioid crisis so before we were
definitely over prescribing oxycodone
and this was like kind of happening
during my medical training where we
started to realize that we're over
treating pain this initially started
obviously with the pharmaceutical
companies playing games and misleading
doctors about whether or not these
medications were addicting but also
because of some of the surveys that we
were giving patients ask them questions
of whether or not their pain was treated
adequately and doctors were seeing
reimbursements fall meaning hospitals
weren't getting paid doctors weren't
being reimbursed for their care because
patients were saying i still had a level
of pain and as a result doctors started
over treating pain in order to get
better patient satisfaction scores but
giving the patients what they want fully
100 full stop may not actually be ideal
for their health a typical situation
could be like what happened to me you
have a horrible injury you're off work
start taking pain medications because
you're actually in pain but then you get
addicted to it so you continue taking
pain medications this isn't about the
opioid crisis in the united states it's
about me most people stop taking them
within six weeks of a surgery but here i
am three months later
still taking high doses of
oxycodone every single day so at some
point you need to figure out a step down
approach or figure out why the pain is
continuing is there something that
surgically needs to be addressed is it
about beginning some sort of rehab
protocol and a very interesting one that
a lot of people don't talk about taking
off opioids can actually reduce pain
kind of an interesting concept it's
paradoxical in nature over the last six
years i've still had lingering effects
anytime i would bend over my knee would
pop and it would be painful here i am
after soccer
icing my knee and it makes me think
that i'm not gonna be able to jump
around and play with my kids is it worth
it to willingly go back and get a
surgery just for the potential just the
possibility of having no pain so there's
a lot of options here there's injectable
options surgical options i know a lot of
people in the medical community like to
poo poo acupuncture and integrative
medicine i think that there is
definitely some value there i've
actually had good outcomes with it for a
patient who's having knee pain of his
age it's reasonable to say
maybe it's time that you don't play
soccer anymore because there's patients
of mine who are 40 years old have had
knee problems knee surgeries in the past
and are playing pickup basketball with
20 year olds and are constantly having
knee pain there's times where in life we
have to admit that maybe we can't do
that anymore and it doesn't mean that
life is terrible it means that
adaptations have to be made some
patients will say i refuse for that to
be the adaptation i'd rather try the
surgery and risk it and that's totally
fine as long as they're aware of those
risks
[Music]
he said that everything went really well
they cleaned out all the scar tissue he
also found a minor meniscus tear which
he fixed meniscus common word used a lot
of patients don't know what it is you
have a big femur bone at the top of your
thigh a slightly smaller bone the tibia
in your shin they sit on top of one
another in order for your knee to move
you need to have good mobility so you
have these two c-shaped pads called a
meniscus a lateral meniscus and a medial
meniscus one's on the outside ones on
the inside and they essentially provide
padding extra stability to the knee they
actually increase surface area of the
knee so you don't have one point of
pressure of the two bones rubbing on
each other i look down and my knee is
swollen up the size of a cantaloupe my
thing is green my leg is green here's
the normal egg here's the cream okay
that's not good i'm not sure if he's
having a blood clot happening there the
swelling is very worrisome to me that
would be like an urgent uh ultrasound a
duplex to see if that there is a clot
forming a lot of times when you're
sedated in a surgery you can have a
higher chance of developing a dvt which
is known as a deep venous thrombosis
where the blood being stagnant in your
veins because you're not moving you're
just laying down forms a clot the danger
of it if it gets dislodged and it
continues into the circulation it can
actually end up in your lungs block off
circulation in your lungs causing a
pulmonary embolism they said i still
[ __ ] out of it so all i did for a period
of five or six days was to sit on the
couch and ice my knee wow
video games are so cool the earlier we
can get even some slight motion
post-surgically in an area that was
operated on the better outcomes we get
and i'm not talking about him going and
starting squatting i'm talking about
just gentle mobility we actually even
have patients that have like robots and
machines do the motion for them just to
articulate the joint just to get that
fluid coming back into that area because
the longer we leave things locked up the
harder it is to unlock them after oh my
god look at that i have little tiny
holes in my knee so that goes to show he
did have arthroscopic surgery because he
had cameras inserted into those holes
and tools and you see that uh marker
there which is weird that they didn't
take that off that just shows that they
were operating on that knee before they
started operating that's how we know you
guys ready to see pictures of the inside
of my knee yeah you betcha this is like
the inside of my knee cavity they have
no idea what the acls and stuff and this
is a giant lump of scar tissue that they
shaved away you could have told me that
these were photos of your unborn child
and they're like oh my god she's
beautiful
the doctor told me you know it'll be a
week of being off your feet and then
i'll be back to normal i can help ariel
out because you know she's still
pregnant and it'll be great as the weeks
go on
my knee doesn't get a ton better today
i'm going to get my sutures taken out
they uh kept them in for an extra couple
of weeks it got through there's the
robot that i was talking about earlier
about getting mobility back into that
knee two weeks three weeks four weeks
and still i couldn't play soccer that's
not a surprise to me four weeks post-op
you're not playing soccer like that's
just the norm i sprained my ankle i
don't expect to play soccer in four
weeks time they gave me a prescription
to
painkillers
so here i am exactly in the place that i
didn't want to be
doing all the things that i didn't want
to do
i have a prescription full of
painkillers and i'm saying to them not
today
that is not the responsible way of
getting rid of painkillers there's
pharmacies that will take them back and
also if you're ever throwing away
medications like that rip your name off
the label just for privacy's sake or at
least black it out just so no one else
can get your info it's time for physical
therapy
look at this guy it's been resistance
bands not wearing many clothing you know
you could just see everything move a
little better i kept at it luckily ariel
was there yeah i mean i don't i honestly
couldn't have done it without ariel i
had the support of a great physical
therapist kept working kept icing it
slowly got better finally several months
after the recovery process
when wes was a
growing up before our very eyes
i got to play my first soccer game very
reasonable time frame out like honestly
when i talk to patients if they're
getting major knee surgery i would say
six to 12 months no soccer so seven
months is totally reasonable
i was able to run full speed on the
field cut back and forth kick the ball
yes sure my knee buckled a couple times
yes sure i wasn't perfect but i was back
to doing the things i enjoyed the most
markiplier also has made videos about
his medical journey click here to check
out my reaction to that and as always
stay happy and healthy i'll see you
markiplier's
[Music]